h good
[Musik]
morning guck mal hier die sind sogar
richtig
[Applaus]
gut und damit J Leute was geht herzlich
Willkommen zu neuen Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut wir befinden
uns hier in Bangkok ich bin gerade noch
im Hotelzimmer nehme aktuell jetzt hier
schnell noch mit meiner großen Kamera
auf heute wird nämlich echt interessant
mein Kumpel moin alles F gut geschlafen
ja
super wir werden uns aufmachen in die
vermutlich größte Slam in ganz Asien
Klong Toy nennt sich das ist ein
Stadtteil hier in Bangkok ich habe das
Ganze im Internet gefunden und ich
dachte mir ey wenn ich schon hier bin
ich bin erstmal froh dass ich nicht
alleine bin weil im Internet sind schon
so ein paar Warnungen ausgesprochen dass
man da ein bisschen aufpassen muss vor
allem wenn es nachts ist und die
Taxifahrer bringen ein dort wohl auch
nicht hin aber wir schauen mal also wir
müssen damit Taxi hinfahren weil es ist
halt 7 km entfernt genau ich muss sagen
ich bin wirklich sehr sehr gespannt das
Ding ist nämlich ich habe sowas
natürlich schon oft auf irgendwelchen
Aufnahmen gesehen oder damals in der
Schule in den geobüchern sind ja of dann
so Fotos von Slams oder z.B in Mexico
City diese reiche Gegend neben die arme
Gegend kennt ihr bestimmt dieses Bild
und ich fand sowas immer schon
interessant war aber noch nie selber in
einer Slam drin es heißt in einem Slam
ich entschuldige mich jetzt schon mal
für die ganzen falschen Aussprachen ich
bin schon zu lange aus der Schule raus
Sprachen lnen Babel und hätte jetzt auch
nicht gedacht dass das mal passiert aber
wir machen das jetzt einfach mal und ich
bin echt gespannt ich hoffe natürlich
dass alle gut
[Musik]
geht aber eigentlich machen mir jetzt
keine Sorgen das wird schon cool und ich
glaube die Leute da sind sicherlich auch
sehr freundlich natürlich gibt's da
Kriminalität deswegen nehme ich meine
große Kamera hier jetzt auch nicht mit
sondern nur die GoPro ja dann ne Mama
falls wir uns nicht wiedersehen hab dich
lieb zur Geschichte erfahrt ihr dann
auch noch was aber ich würde sagen wir
gehen jetzt erstmal los weil wir haben
auch schon 14 Uhr um 18 Uhr wird's hier
dunkel und ich muss da jetzt auch dann
nicht im Dunkeln direkt rumlaufen wenn
ich zum ersten Mal dort bin und sowas
Besuche aber auf Fotos war echt schon
cool aus da fahren auch so Züge durch ne
ihr kennt ja bestimmt diesen Mark der so
hochgeklappt wird das ist jetzt dort
nicht aber so ähnlich sieht es auch aus
deswegen Leute gar nicht lange labern
auf geht's geht ja willkommen vor
unserem Hotel sieht so aus hier ist
irgendwie immer Stau weil hier wird so
eine U-Bahn gebaut wir gehen jetzt erst
noch kurz zum 7-Eleven eine Kleinigkeit
frühstücken weil wir haben noch nicht
wirklich was gegessen heute ich habe ja
letztens relativ zufällig dieses Video
in dubaii gedreht wo ich dadurch das
Armen viiertel gesteppt bin und das ist
echt sehr sehr gut bei euch angekommen
dafür auch noch mal vielen Dank und für
die gan
positiven Kommentare da habe ich einige
echt ja sehr sehr nette Sachen gelesen
und deswegen wurde ich auch so ein
bisschen ermutigt das mal öfter zu
machen das habt ihr auch gesagt und ich
habe dann halt mal geschaut wo ist in
Asien vielleicht sowas was man verfilmen
kann oder wo man mal hingehen kann und
habe dann halt Klong to gefunden und
dachte mir das müssen wir auf jeden Fall
uns mal anschauen und darüber einen
Bericht drehen ich habe mein portemon
auch nicht mitgenommen ich habe jetzt
hier nur ein bisschen Bargeld drin hast
du dein pman mit nein ich habe genauso
viel Bargeld mit D es reicht dass Sie
zufrieden sind wenn sie uns
bedrohen
hallo so für mich gibt's jetzt so ein
paar instant Nudeln die gibt's hier
überall die sind eigentlich ganz lecker
und so ein jakult in Deutschland ist das
voll teuer hier kostet das nur paar Cent
das trinke ich mir gerne einmal am Tag
ein merry christmas merry
christmas dann wird jetzt das grabtaxi
bestellt und dann geht's ab nach Klong
Toy ich bin echt gespannt wir fragen uns
gerade warum die hier so viele Gitter
vor den Balkonen haben was das für eine
für ein Sinn macht was hast du gesagt
entweder für Kinder oder
einbruchsicher ich würde tippen damit
die Kinder da nicht rausfallen aber ihr
könnt es ja gerne mal in die Kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr es wisst so jetzt
schauen wir mal ob wir hier einen
graaptaxi bekommen ob uns da irgend
mitnimmt als Adresse habe ich jetzt
erstmal Klong Toy market ausgewählt das
ist wohl auch ein touristenpunkt
deswegen da werden wir auf jeden Fall
jetzt hingebracht und von da aus müssen
wir denke ich dann laufen
hallo
Alex okay
okay
auf jeden Fall andere Welt hier ne muss
man sagen aber cool noch kurz ein paar
Information zu dem slamgebiet und zwar
habe ich ja schon gesagt es wird
geschätzt dass dort zwischen 70 aber bis
zu 120 000 Menschen leben genau kann man
es halt nicht sagen und in der Nähe ist
der Hafen und deswegen haben sich da ab
den 1950er Jahren sehr viele billige
Arbeitskräfte angesiedelt die dann
teilweise dort in ja einfachen Hütten
gelebt haben da kam dann immer mehr
Menschen hinzu und die thailändische
Regierung hat auch mal versucht den
ganzen Slam auf zuulösen um diesen Platz
halt wieder einnehmen zu können um dort
mehr Hafen Gebäude Hallen und so weiter
zu errichten doch dann gab es ein
Aufstand und die haben dann irgendwann
akzeptiert dass das nichts bringt und
dort jetzt halt ja dieses Gebiet so
akzeptiert logischerweise gibt's da halt
keine Polizei und so da geht halt alles
so denke ich nach den Regeln der
Einwohner deswegen genau das Richtige
für uns
absolut zu den Locals zu den l gehen wir
heute
ja ja gut dass ich den Alex dabei hab ja
ich bin ja auch jetzt hier fleißig am
trainieren und
AU hening macht dir keine Sorgen danke
dir ich bin ja auch der hübsch von uns
beiden wir brauchen übrigens für 8 km
eine Stunde
ja ist hier alles bisschen verstopft ja
thank you thank you much bye bye bye bye
okay Leute wir sind angekommen hier
gegenüber ist jetzt der Klong Toy Mark
und dahinter ist dann das Gebiet wo wir
ein bisschen rumsppen wollen sollen wir
hier mal über die Brücke gehen ja ist
auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Geruch
hier in der Luft was hast du gesagt
nicht nach geschlachteten hünern er
kennt sich
aus ich muss auch sagen ich werde jetzt
nicht so viel kuten in dem Video das
wird sicherlich auch ein bisschen länger
aber ja wird sicher
spannend soll wir hier und dann da
durchgehen
boah also ich muss sagen ich habe mich
ja schon eigentlich an die Gerüche
gewohnt aber hier ist es noch mal ganz
extrem ja komm los geht's also wie
gesagt das hier ist jetzt erst der Klong
Toy
market hier gibt's halt alles mögliche
an Fisch und sowas und halt auch ganz
viel Fleisch der da hinter mir trägt
gerade einfach ein durchgeschnittenes
Schwein auf seinem
Rücken ich noch nie gesehen alter Falter
hier sieht man jetzt noch einmal die
Wolkenkratzer und hier sieht's dann
schon anders aus und in diese Richtung
gehen wir jetzt mal weiter und bevor wir
jetzt weiter reingehen wollte ich euch
auch noch den Sponsor des heutigen
Videos vorstellen ich freue mich
übrigens sehr über die Zusammenarbeit
weil es bei mir einfach perfekt
reinpasst es ist Bubble und Bubble ist
eine spracha kennen wahrscheinlich viele
von euch schon falls nicht habt ihr auf
jeden Fall was verpasst weil damit kann
man einige Fremdsprachen ruckzuck lernen
und ich stell die App euch jetzt mal
kurz vor okay Leute wie Ihr sehen können
habe ich mittlerweile schon die Location
gewechselt wir sind gerade auf kusamui
angekommen und ich nutze jetzt hier die
Gunst der Stunde die Sonne ist gerade
schon untergegangen um euch einmal
Bubbel zu zeigen ich versuche mich zwar
was me meine Englisch Skills angeht
immer weiter zuilden und ich bin ja
jetzt auch viel unterwegs und komme mit
vielen Leuten ins Gespräch aber Englisch
ist ja die Weltsprache und ich brauche
das eigentlich überall und deshalb ist
es umso schöner dass mir Bubble da noch
ein bisschen unter die Arme grei man
muss die ein bisschen für sich selber
programmieren kann auswählen was möchte
ich lernen Grammatik mit welchem
Schwerpunkt hab ich z.B Reisen bestimmt
und so sieht dann z.B eine Lektion aus
gut das ist jetzt relativ easy friendly
man hört halt immer wie es ausgesprochen
wird old ein alter Freund alte Freundin
ja das ist wirklich jetzt für ganz dumme
das lernt man in der fünften Klasse
außerdem könnt ihr hier sehen es gibt
zertifizierte Sprachlehrer ihr könnt
euch bei Online talks und Onlinekurse
anmelden z.B bei ibim kostenlos eine
Stunde buchen und testen außerdem gibt's
jede Menge Podcasts Hörübungen sogar
auch ein paar Spiele um bisschen
Abwechslung reinzubringen natürlich kann
man nicht nur Englisch lernen es gibt
insgesamt 14 Sprachen die Babel anbietet
darunter natürlich die am meist
gesprochenen Sprachen der Welt die man
auch braucht meine Französisch Skills
aus der Schule könn ich z.B auch noch
mal ein bisschen upgraden und das coole
ist die App bildet sich automatisch
immer weiter es gibt Tausende von
Nutzern die jeden Tag Content füllen mit
denen ihr interagieren könnt und so
weiter und so fort also wirklich meine
Meinung nach die die coolste Sprache die
es aktuell gibt wenn ihr euch bei Babbel
über den Link der in der
Videobeschreibung ist anmeldet bekommt
ihr sogar auf das lifetime Abo 60%
Rabatt das glaube ich eine coole Aktion
damit würdet ihr mich auf jeden Fall
auch supporten dann kann ich euch Bubble
auch vielleicht hin und wieder noch mal
vorstellen bei anderen coolen
reiseprojekten genau also vielen Dank
noch mal an bbble und jetzt machen wir
weiter mit dem Slam Video es war noch
echt es WD noch richtig cool eigentlich
habe ich ja gesagt dass das hier auch
touristischer ist zumindest dieser Markt
aber eigentlich sind wir die
einzen GI kostet in Deutschland viel ne
ja gut ich neh 2 l mit 42 BT also so
langsam sind wir jetzt auf jeden Fall
weg vom Markt bin ich auch ganz froh
drum hier riecht's jetzt ein bisschen
angenehmer und ich bin jetzt echt mal
gespannt was da noch so kommt ich habe
natürlich vorher online auch so ein paar
Videos und Bilder mir angeguckt
allerdings sind wir glaube ich noch
nicht ganz richtig das müsste irgendwie
dann da hinten noch kommen aber hier
sieht's natürlich auch
schon interessant aus im Vergleich zu
der Armen Hälfte von Dubai natürlich
noch mal was ganz anderes ne also ich
glaube so ein so eine heruntergekommene
ärmliche Gegend habe ich in echt noch n
irgendwo gesehen aber es wird ja
sicherlich noch extremer wie war das in
Brasilien sah das da schlimmer aus war
mehr Wellblech als Beton ach so ja genau
hier ist noch recht viel Beton ja krass
die haben ja aber sogar ein
Sportplatz guck mal hier die sind sogar
richtig gut Alter
stark ja es ist halt ein bisschen
vermüllt und das sieht auch nicht so aus
wie bei uns die Sportplätze aber cool zu
sehen ja okay da ist guck mal vielleicht
ist das sind natürlich dann schon eher
so Blechhütten
ne ja okay weiter geht's
hey ist das nicht ein bisschen
gefährlich mit den Stromleitung
anscheinend nicht die kleinen Jungs die
klettern hier zwischen den Stromleitung
her ich glaube jetzt geht's hier los wow
okay guck mal da willst du lieber da
lang oder hier
lang
Kinder stim sind echt viele Kinder SAS
habe ich noch komm hier
lang wow ich
nicht Katze und
hühnerü de jr
verü
hner die frei rumlaufen ich habe
irgendwie total Panik
davor irgendwie
komisch ja hier returen fange ich wieder
an
[Musik]
ja ich auch gedacht ich bin wirklich ich
find es schon krass ja ich glaub nicht
dass wir
weiter wenn die sagen man kommt hier
weiter dann wird das doch wohl stimmen
oder dass das ein Haus ist ich glaube
hier kann man durchgehen
[Musik]
hier wow
Alter Stromleitung stimmt das ist ja
verrückt
auch so gerade hier diese Gänge habe ich
schon gesehen so auf Videos aber wenn
man selber noch mal so hier ist und hier
so lang steppt hier wohnen ja über
Leute ist das schon noch mal was
anderes Alter und wie schon gesagt hier
wohnen bis zu 120 000 Menschen alle 10
mal ne
ja auch krass hier wieder der Kontrast
wir sind jetzt gerade auf der anderen
Seite hier ist noch ein Autohändler mit
schönen modernen Autos und hier geht's
jetzt halt wieder rein hier ist der
regionale Baustoff hier lang oder da
[Musik]
lang das hier durchgehen oder oder warte
ich will einmal gucken was hier drin
[Musik]
ist hey ganz viel
Bier wow Alter soll mal auf dem
Bolzplatz hallo h hallo morning g
morning
hi
ja freundlich ach komm
hier also ich finde die alle sehr ich
habe jetzt hier keine Angst oder so
eigentlich WD uns ja schon gesagt dass
man ein bisschen aufpassen sollte
nee alle sehr zu vorkommt und freundlich
ja hier geht's nicht weiter we nicht was
Haus ist und nicht hier lang
ja hallo willst du sollen wir uns was zu
trinken holen
ja hey was brauchst
du
hallo ach guck mal sie hat hieren noch
was ja okay so jetzt haben wir erstmal
was zu trinken
bekommen 40 B ein ein so Drink hier ne B
weniger
als aber das ist ja auch nicht
die
was war
das
hier hier
oder
hallo
hallo die hat
gehauen
ah hier sind wir jetzt von der anderen
Seite ich würde da gerne mal mitspielen
soll ich mal fragen was machen
dann also hier leben auf jeden Fall alle
Tiere friedlich zusammen wir haben Hunde
da hinten Hühner und da ist ein voll
nicer Hund falls ihr den hier sehen
könnt den hier meine ich
ja ne so muss sein so muss
sein
[Applaus]
เอ vs UK เฮ้ย vs
รัด V mi
น แมซี่ โอ้โ เ ไม่ รู้
อ่ะ
you กิง
ญี่ปุ่น เหี้
มานี่มกโ เท ของ เท เ อยู่ ประเทศ เยรมี
เอา ดิ
hast gesehen ich habe zwei Punkte
gemacht ja gut jetzt gehen wir noch da
vorne rum ich muss sagen ich fin echt
entspannend ja die haben mich auch von
alleine gefragt ob ich Bocke
mitzpielen also hab da natürlich auch
mein Bestes gegeben wie früher beim
Fußball Fußball spielen kann ich das war
jetzt zwar ein bisschen anders weil der
Ball so leicht nachgegeben hat der war
auch glaube ich aus Plastik oder so der
Ball aber war cool nur ich krieg mein
Fuß nicht so weit hoch wie die und
irgendwo fährt hier auch jetzt so ein
Zug durch den wollten wir uns so
angucken eine Sache die ich noch sagen
wollte es ist cool so weil die ganzen
Kinder die freuen sich so darüber glaube
ich Europäer zu sehen oder Leute die
halt nicht von hier kommen und
normalerweise ist es ja immer so dass
sie dann einem die ganze Zeit
irgendwelche Sachen verkaufen wollen
oder dass man den halt Geld gibt aber
das ist hier gar nicht so also die haben
immer nur Hallo gesagt irgendwas gerufen
und sich gefreut das war echt ganz süß
sehr angeneh ja okay weiter geht's wobei
wir jetzt hier eher wieder bei so einer
Einkaufs m sind halt alles ein bisschen
einfacher natürlich aber
ja Ventilator wer was ich glaub mein
ganzer Rücken ist nass oder
ja also heute ist extrem heiß hier
ja
okay okay sie zeigt uns jetzt glaube ich
den Eingang weil hier war jetzt wieder
Sackgasse das ist ja nett von
ihr das ist Zuckerrohr okay super und
hier haben wir jetzt einfach die
Schienen die hier durch verlaufen hallo
in Deutschland wird ja immer gewarnt
davor influenzer Bilder auf Schienen zu
machen hier ist das anscheinend nicht so
nicht so eng gesehen weil die sitzen da
ja sogar hinten drauf ja e das sieht ja
wirklich verrückt aus guck dir mal das
Bild an da will ich ein Foto machen
Alter ey Leute es sieht ja wirklich
crazy aus das muss man sagen ne ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie oft hier Züge kommen
aber vermutlich wissen die ja Bescheid
den sch dass sich melden die Züge WN
kommen
h hier willst du noch was
trinken such was aus hier setz dich h
erstmal wieder eine kleine Stärkung so
kleine Stärkung jetzt geht's weiter bin
ich mal gespannt was hier kommt wir
haben gerade übrigens erfahren kannst
euch vorgehen wenn du magst hier fahren
schon noch Züge aber wohl nur einmal die
Woche also heute kommt kein Zug mehr das
ist ganz gut deswegen sitzen ja auch
alle einfach auf den Schienen
hallo so einmal auf Schienen gehen ja
einmal auf in Deutschland traue ich mich
das nicht ne ne nachher kommt da noch
ein zwei stundiger verspäteter ICE rüber
gedüst wer weiß das
schon
K oh vorsichtig hat Angst vor dir wegen
ihrem Essen ach so dies diese kleinen
Päckchen was ist das noch mal
Waschmittel das ist eine gute Frage das
habe ich schon malendwo gesehen ich find
es auch interessant dass es hier überall
so kleine Läden gibt aber wir sind ja
wirklich die einzigen hier wer kauft das
jetzt hier gerade Leute ne ja aber also
viel ist ja ja nicht
los hallo da hier da sind die
Waschmaschinen bestimt wasch
Waschmaschine und hier kannst du duschen
ja echt crazy ne also wir sind alle mit
unserem deutschen Standard groß geworden
aber und dann ist das ja irgendwie
selbstverständlich irgendwann aber ist
es ja eigentlich nicht ich muss sagen
das eigentlich mein Highlight bis jetzt
dass hier diese Schienen sind und man
hier einfach lang gehen kann und links
und rechts so kleine Häuser und da vorne
haben wir dann wieder die
Hochhäuser hing so langsam wird dunkel
und es wde ja gesagt wenn dunkel ist
besser hier nicht lang gehen aber ich
muss sagen ich habe eigentlich gar keine
Angst mehr also ich hatte jetzt auch nie
Angst davor nur natürlich hat man ein
bisschen Respekt weil man weiß ja nicht
wie viel oder was hier so abgeht nur
alle Leute sind echt richtig freundlich
und ich würde ja auch glaube ich
übernachten irgendwo hier gibt's auch
Hotels habe ich bei Google gesehen
zumindest in der Nähe hier guck mal so
Express oh J
hey
[Musik]
hallo
kannst du mich noch
mal
nassen
hallo ich glaub die fand
guting das ist doch hier die Köln
Frankfurt die neue highped
Strecke
einoch he crazy ne also Henning sagt die
werden hier in den nächsten Jahren auf
jeden Fall das ganze auflösen weil hier
die wolkenkratz immer näher dran kommen
aber ich glaube die Bewohner hier die
haben wir schon mal ein Aufstand gemacht
und es hat funktioniert deswegen drücke
ich den auf jeden Fall die Däumchen dass
sie hier wohnen bleiben können ja auf
jeden Fall hello da war die K vor uns
könnt ihr jetzt so Hähne sehen das sind
wohl richtige Kampfhähne die machen den
so Rasierklingen dran und dann gibt's
hier in Thailand so haenkämpfe wo man
dann auf die Wetten kann das ist
eigentlich illegal aber wird irgendwie
geduldet oder so keine Ahnung
schon auf jeden Fall bisschen verrückt
da vorne ist gleich
vorbei
hier
hier er versteckt sich
er hat ihn so die Sonne ist bereits
untergegangen und wir werden jetzt das
Gebiet wieder verlassen und in Richtung
Zentrum fahren es war auf jeden Fall
super cool hier und das sind immer so
kleine Erlebnisse die man nicht vergisst
auch vor allem hier mit dieser
Zugstrecke und allen möglichen drum und
dran also auch wirklich richtig viele
nette Menschen und ich glaube hier ist
auch ein cooles Video entstanden Henning
hat's auch gefallen glaube ich abonniert
sehr gerne den Kanal ich ma sowas
sicherlich in Zukunft auch noch mal
öfter checkt Bubble ab wenn ihr noch ein
paar Fremdsprachen lernen wollt jetzt
wird ja auch wieder lauter und wir sehen
uns hier schon ganz bald wieder auf
meinem zweit Kanal kommen auch viele
Vlogs die halt nicht ja auf meinen
ersten Channel passen einfach so ein
bisschen mehr von meinem privaten wie
wir abends rum Steppen was wir so machen
auf jeden Fall auch sehr unterhaltsam
checkt das gerne aus ansonsten danke
fürs zuschauen haut rein Leute bis zum
nächsten Mal ciao